Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie und werde das Erstgespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen.
Und da sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht, mich zu unterbrechen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Marina Nowak, Herr Doktor.
Ich buchtebiere mal eben N-O-V-A-K, oder?
Nicht V-W-Nowak.
Den Vornamen M-A-L-I-N-A.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Nowak?
Ja, ich bin 29.
Ihr Geburtstatum bitte.
10. August 1996.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 76.
Ihr Gewicht bitte.
Ja, soll ich sagen oder muss ich mit teilen, mein Gewicht?
Ja, das ist wichtig für uns.
Ja, 150 Kilogramm bin ich.
150 oder 50?
50, Herr Doktor.
Ich bin Übergewicht, deswegen haben Sie Sorgen.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen.
Was sind Sie von Beruf Frau Nowak?
Ja, ich bin Stauberaterin.
Aber ich arbeite halbzeit.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie heißt er oder sie?
Ja, Herr Wolfgang Stark.
Mein Hausarzt heißt Wolfgang Stark.
Was für Sie heute ist uns, Frau Nowak?
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ehrlich zu sagen,
mir geht es schon seit Jahren richtig schief mit meinem Bau.
Ich habe immer Bau krempfe.
Seit einem Jahr.
Seit 5 Jahren vielleicht. Seit Jahren.
Seit 5 Jahren.
Das ein Schmerzen oder?
Krempfe, habe ich Schmerzen, Krempfe.
Seit 5 Jahren.
Ich habe immer zusammen gequetschen.
Mein Bau ist komisch.
Sind die Beschwerden dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Ja, manchmal geht, manchmal kommt zurück.
Momentan haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, ja, natürlich. Deswegen bin ich hier.
Wo genau tut es Ihnen weh?
Ganzbau.
Oberbau oder Rechtszeit?
Nein, ich kann nicht das beschreiben. Ganzbau.
Ich habe jetzt auch Durchfall.
Wie lange haben Sie Durchfall?
Seit 3 Tagen habe ich jetzt.
Aber manchmal habe ich Durchfall mit Bauchschmerzen.
Gestern habe ich 5 Mal zum Klo gegangen.
Wie sieht Ihr Stuhl aus?
Wasserig.
Welches Stuhl hat Ihr Stuhl?
Wasser.
Haben Sie etwas verdoben gegessen?
Nein, ich esse immer gleich Dinge.
Sie essen wie sonst?
Ja, aber mir ist aufgefallen, dass wenn ich Milchprodukte esse, trinke, habe ich immer Bauchschmerzen.
Ich habe früher öfters ignoriert, aber das geht immer schief.
Ich habe gedacht, das geht weg.
Das ist wichtig für uns, diese Info.
Waren Sie schon beim Hausarzt?
Ja, ja, letztes Jahr habe ich meinen Hausarzt besucht.
Was hat er gesagt?
Er hat mir eine Tablette geschrieben, aber sie hat mir nicht geholfen.
Welche Tablette wissen Sie das?
Ja, es war Methos-Spasmil.
Nicht geholfen, oder?
Nicht geholfen, nein.
In welcher Dosis wissen Sie das?
Das war letztes Jahr.
Verstehe.
Können Sie mir diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Dumpf stechen, drücken.
Sie haben schon Krampfartikel gesagt?
Krampfartikel und ja, ich fühle mich drückgefühlt.
Und manchmal, das ist Dumpf, ganz Bauch.
Manchmal bläht sich mein Bauch auf, wie ein 5. Monat Schwanger.
Wie Schwangerschaft.
Sie haben volle Gefühle?
Ja, volle Gefühle und ich kann sagen, mein Bauch ist manchmal dick geworden.
Haben Sie aufgestoßen?
Ja, manchmal.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen von 1 bis 10, wobei 10 am stärksten ist?
Nicht sehr schlimm. Jetzt habe ich vielleicht mit 5.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, nein habe ich.
Müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Frau Novak?
Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht, habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchkrampf habe ich.
Haben Sie Atemnot aufgefallen?
Nein, nein habe ich keine Atemprobleme.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Herzrasen oder Herzstorben?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Das ist peinlich, aber ich muss immer pupsen.
Sehr oft muss ich pupsen.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Gas geben.
Pupsen.
Gibt es irgendetwas, das die Beschwerden schlimmer oder besser macht?
Sie haben schon gesagt, nach dem Milch Einnahme wird es schlimmer.
Ja, ja, nach dem Milchprodukt.
Wenn ich trinke, wenn ich Eis esse, wenn ich eine Süßigkeit Milch esse,
ich fühle diese Schmerzen immer.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, nein, habe ich keine Fieber.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost, Nachschweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit drei Tagen kann ich nicht gut essen wegen Durchfall oder Bauchkrampf.
Bauchkrampf kann man nicht essen, Herr Doktor.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zugewonnen?
Ja, vielleicht zwei oder drei Kilo habe ich.
Ich weiß nicht genau, aber...
Abgenommen, oder?
Ja, abgenommen.
In welcher Zeitraum haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, ich kann sagen, oder in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Zwei oder drei Kilo, ich weiß nicht, aber...
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen? Wie meinen Sie, was meinen Sie?
Ich meine Urin. Wie ist Ihr Urin?
Mein Urin ist Gelb.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Nein, habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Ich gehe immer gleich, drei oder viermal pro Tag.
Gut zu hören, Frau Nowak.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, gestern musste ich zur Toilette gehen.
Deswegen könnte ich gestern Abend nicht gut schlafen.
Wegen Durchfall, oder?
Haben Sie Einschlafstörungen oder Durchschlafstörungen?
Ja, ich musste aufwachen wegen Bauchcreme.
Was haben Sie gestern gegessen?
Gestern?
Oder getrunken? Ja, haben Sie Milch getrunken?
Ich habe seit zwei oder drei Tagen ähnliche Schmerzen.
Vor drei Tagen habe ich ein Milchprodukt gegessen.
Mit Joghurt und etwas Süßheit.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Chronische Erkrankungen, Frau Nowak?
Nein, ich bin gesund.
Aber ich bin übergewicht. Deswegen kann ich nicht gut bewegen.
Verstehe. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Ich nehme regelmäßig Verhütungsmittel.
Welche Tablette nehmen Sie?
Yasmin. Yasmin Tablette mit Jod.
In welche Dosis wissen Sie das?
Ich weiß nicht, Herr Doktor.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als ich Kind war, wurden meine Mandeln entfernt.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Ungefähr acht.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, ich habe einmal operiert.
Als ich Kind war, bin ich wegen Durchfall im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Fünf Tage.
Wegen Durchfall? Ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich habe vollen Allergien.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Mit Schnupfen und Jücken.
Jükreis.
Rauchen Sie Frauenwag?
Nein, niemals.
Gut zu hören.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke am Wochenende.
Was trinken Sie? Ein Schnaps oder ein Bier.
Ein Schnaps bedeutet ein Glas, oder?
Ein Schnaps, eine Flasche Schnaps oder eine Flasche Bier.
Ein Flasche Bier.
Nur am Wochenende.
Jedes Wochenende, oder?
Manchmal jeden, manchmal einmal pro zwei Wochen.
Nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich aus medizinischen Gründen?
Fragen wie immer. Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, niemals.
Gut. Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Nowak?
Ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Mann Susann?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe ein Kind.
Ist er oder sie gesund?
Ja, er ist gesund.
Herr Doktor, mit Geburt habe ich 4 Kilo abgenommen und nicht zu genommen.
Ich habe 40 Kilo abgenommen und nach dem Geburt konnte ich nicht einnehmen.
Wir haben eine Abteilung nach der Untersuchung.
Sie können eine Beratung nehmen.
Ich kann es organisieren. Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen bitte, Frau Nowak.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bei Ihrer Familie?
Ich meine Ihre Mutter, Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist leider mit 50 an Diktam-Karzinom verstorben.
Mein Beileid tut mir leid zu hören, Frau Nowak.
Ihre Mutter?
Ich habe sie seit 5 Jahren gestorben.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, er ist auch übergewicht.
Kann das genetisch sein, Herr Doktor?
Ja, es könnte sein, Frau Nowak.
Genetische Veranlagung ist wichtig.
Haben Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, vollständig.
Meine Gegenkinderkrankheit, Covid 19?
Ja, ich habe alle Impfungen gehabt.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, letztes Jahr waren wir in Spanien im Urlaub.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, Frau Nowak?
Ich bekomme seit 5 Jahren Bauchrämpfe.
Gibt es eine Lösung? Was vermuten Sie?
Wie gesagt, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Es ist nur ein Anamnesgespräch.
Wir werden eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Wir würden eine operative Diagnostik vornehmen.
Mit den Ergebnissen können wir mehr darüber sprechen.
Ich habe im Internet gesehen, dass eine Koloskopie nötig ist.
Würden Sie eine Koloskopie durchführen?
Wie gesagt, es ist zu früh, etwas genauer zu sagen.
Nach den Ergebnissen können wir entscheiden, ob eine Koloskopie nötig ist.
Ich habe Angst über Koloskopien.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wir können Beruhigungsmittel verabreichen.
Es ist eine schmerzhafte Therapie.
Aber wir können Beruhigungsmittel verabreichen.
Deswegen machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich habe auch sterben gedacht.
Mein Vater ist sehr jung gestorben.
Ich war übergewacht.
Plötzlich ist er gestorben.
Ich habe auch das Risiko, sterben zu können.
Es ist zu früh, etwas genauer zu sagen.
Aber wir tun alles für Sie.
Vielen Dank.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen Patienten vorstellen,
den ich in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hätten Sie kurz gesagt?
Welche Symptome hat die Patientin?
Sie hat krampfartige Bauchschmerzen.
Okay.
Sie können eine Kurse aufklären.
Es geht um Marina Novak.
Eine 29-jährige Patientin.
Geboren am 10.08.1996.
1,76 Meter groß.
1,76 Meter.
1,50 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund,
seit fünf Jahren bestehende,
zunehmende, drückende,
krampfartige Bauchschmerzen oder Abdominalgie
im ganzen Bauch.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 5 von 10 bewertet.
Sie war für diese Beschwerden schon beim Hausarzt.
Er habe Methospasmiel verschrieben.
Aber es hat ihm nicht gereicht.
Er teilte mit den Beschwerden.
Er verschlimmerte sich nach Milchprodukten.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegen Meteorismus
auf voller Gefühl vor.
Die Frage nach Husten, Herzrhythmus,
Störungen, Brustschmerzen wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig
bis auf Inappetenz.
Seit zwei bis drei Tagen wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Die Jahre seit drei Tagen.
Insomnias wegen der Bauchschmerzen.
An Vorerkrankungen.
Blut in Stuhl?
Ich habe nicht besonders gefragt.
Aber ich habe über den Stuhl gefragt.
Es war nur wasrig.
Er wurde wie Wasser beschreit.
Er hatte keine Vorerkrankungen.
Er nahm regelmäßig Jasmin für Verhütung.
Bei ihm wurde mit acht Jahren eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt.
Er wurde wegen der Jahre stationär behandelt.
Als er Kind war.
Er hatte eine Allergie gegen Polen.
Sie äußerte sich mit Feroz und Hautauschlag.
Sie ist nicht trauer.
Sie trinke ein Flaschen Schnaps oder ein Flaschen Bier.
Wochenlich.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie hat einen gesunden Sohn.
In der Familienanamnese war es eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Bei der Mutter.
Übergewichtig.
Oder obesit.
Sein Vater ist mit 50 Jahren an Kolonkarsinon verstorben.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdacht Diagnose lautet auf Laktoseintoleranz.
Dafür schiebt es typische Symptome.
Wie.
Mischprodukt.
Ein Name.
Mischprodukte.
Und differential Diagnostik kommen.
Die differential Diagnostik kommen.
Und.
Da ist ein Syndrome.
In der Diagnostik würde ich bei der Patientin eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie in Körperleon?
Eigentlich erwarte ich keine besonderen Befunde im Laktosintoleranz.
Danach würde ich eine Laboruntersuchung durchführen, um Blutbildentzündungswerte und Thyroidswerte 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 zu bestimmen.
Es könnte Hypotheriose sein. Um eine Hypotheriose auszuschließen, würde ich diese Laboruntersuchung durchführen.
Als operative Diagnostik würde ich eine Magenspiegelung oder eine Magenspiegelung Koloskopi durchführen.
Magenspiegelung, was meinen Sie?
Endoskopi.
Esopago-DoA-Denoskopi.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich mich Produkteversicht empfehlen und Ernährungsberatung empfehlen.
Hat der Patient schon eine Laktosfriedheit ausprobiert?
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich fragen.
Oder hat der Patient immer Durfall, wenn er Milchprodukte annehmen will?
Nach der Milchprodukteannahme hat er immer ähnliche Beschwerden, Durfall und krampfartige Schmerzen.
Denken Sie einen Laktosbelastungstest für den Patienten?
Ich kenne diesen Test nicht.
Nicht? Okay.
Wie können Sie die bestimmte Diagnose bestellen?
Nach der Milchprodukteannahme sollte ich die
Ernährungsberatung bestellen.
Okay, die anderen Arbeitslager.
Warum machen Sie eine Ozefago-Gasre-DoA-Denoskopi? Erwarten Sie eine Bestimmtheit für Laktosintoleranz?
Um eine andere mögliche Pathologie auszuschließen, werde ich die Ozefago-DoA-Denoskopi durchführen.
Und wie groß ist die Patientin?
Sie ist 1,76 Meter.
Dann habe ich es falsch gesagt.
Können Sie die Koloskopi aufklären?
Koloskopi ist eine diagnostische Methode, mit der können wir Dickdarm oder Kolon darstellen.
Koloskopi ist nicht nur eine diagnostische Methode, sondern auch eine therapeutische Methode.
Wir können ein Polyp oder ein Gewebe entnehmen.
Es ist eine schmerzhafte Diagnose-Untersuchung.
Deswegen verabreichen wir Beruhigungsmittel.
Die Patientin sollte vor der Untersuchung vorbereitet werden.
Wir geben eine Diät.
Nach der Untersuchung braucht die Patientin eine begleitende Person wegen der Beruhigungsmittel.
Diese Patientin leidet an Adipositas.
Wir können den Body Mass Index messen.
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht.
Was ist Body Mass Index?
Body Mass Index bedeutet Kilogramm.
Ich weiß nicht, was das heißt in Deutsch.
Das kann Rete sein.
Das kann man auch als Parallel.
Das ist die Grosse.
Aber das ist die Doppelgrosse.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist.
Danke, Yavuzhan.
Sie empfehlen den Patienten eine Laktos-Free-Diät.
Ja, ich empfehle die Patienten eine Laktos-Free-Diät.
Laktosversicht, Ernährungsberatung und körperliche Belastung.
Regelmäßige Sport.
Warum haben die Patienten keine Gewichtabnahme?
Ich habe diese Fragen auch nicht gestellt.
Warum haben die anderen so eine Abnahme?
Keine Ahnung.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Sie vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, habe ich. Bitte schön.
Ich berichte über die 29-jährige Patientin Marina Novak.
Sie ist 1,76 Meter groß und wiegt 150 Kilogramm.
Die Patientin stand heute bei uns mit seit fünf Jahren bestehenden,
koligartigen, persistierenden, diffusen Abdominalschmerzen mit wassereger Diarrhofen.
Außerdem klagt sie über Asteni, Flatulenz und Meteorismus.
Die Patientin ist aufgefallen, dass ihre Beschwerden nach dem Milchprodukt-Einnahme aufgetreten sind.
Fragen nach Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß, Tachikardie, Nausea und Emesis wurden vermeint.
Beide Patienten sind mit Polynose oder Polynallergie bekannt, die durch Pruritis und Schnaufen aussehen.
Sie sind vollständig geimpft.
Sie sind unaufwendig vor Erkrankungen.
Sie haben einmal eine stationäre Behandlung wegen Diarrhofen.
Sie wurden wegen Tonsillitis im Kindesalt operiert.
In der sozialen Anamnese gab sie ein Verheiratungsgeschehen und ein Gezünd Kind zu haben.
Sie ist eine Sahabearbeiterin.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Laktosintoleranz hin.
Die Differentialdiagnostik ist sehr common.
Die chronische Endstunde der Erkrankungen,
die Erkrankungen von Morbus Crohn, Colitis ulcerosa oder Gastroenteritis
sowie Colon-Carsinom in Betracht.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen werde ich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Besonders bei der Palpation achtet darauf, ob Abwehrspannung oder Druckdolenz,
bei der Oskultation achtet darauf, ob erhöhte Darmgeräusch gibt.
Die Diagnostik der Arten werde ich durchführen, um mögliche Tumoren oder intraabdominal Pathologien auszuschließen.
Ich werde die Gastroosephagodendroskopie oder Koloskopie durchführen,
um mögliche Magen oder Darmcarsinom auszuschließen.
Ich werde auch Blut abnehmen,
besonders Entzündungsparameter bestimmen lassen,
um mögliche chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankungen auszuschließen.
Ich werde auch Nieren und Leberwerte bestimmen lassen.
Welche Parameter meinen Sie?
Entschuldigung, Herr Roberts?
CRP und BSG besonders werde ich bestimmen lassen,
um meine Verdachtstestdiagnose zu bestimmen.
Okay. Und würden Sie diese Patienten stationär oder ambulant behandeln?
Wenn die Zustand der Patienten nicht gut ist, werde ich sie stationär aufnehmen.
Seit drei Tagen hat die Patientin eine starke Diarrhea.
Ich würde sie gerne stationär aufnehmen und einen Zugang legen.
Ich werde auch ausführliche Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Generell werde ich Antibiotika verabreichen und Schmerzmittel durch Zugang verabreichen.
Okay. Und würden Sie ein Konzil anfordern?
Ja. Ein gastroenterologisches Konzil ist sinnvoll, um meine Verdachtstestdiagnose zu bestimmen und die Behandlung zu optimieren.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Abdominalzonographie durchführen.
Könnten Sie bitte Abdominalzonographie erklären?
Abdominalzonographie ist eine Bildgebende für mich.
Ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Um besonders intraabdominal oder weich Pathologien zu bestimmen, nutzen wir Sonographie.
Sonographie hat ohne Strahlung und ohne Risiko.
Es dauert zwischen 10 und 20 Minuten.
Die Patientin liegt sich auf dem Lichtdisch.
Gibt es ein Risiko oder Komplikationen bei dieser Untersuchung?
Ja. Diese Untersuchung ist risikoarm.
Es gibt keine Strahlung oder wir spritzen keine Medikamente ein wegen dieser Untersuchung.
Deswegen sind die Risiken sehr wenig.
Benötigt die Patientin eine spezielle Vorbereitung für diese Untersuchung?
Manchmal ist es so hart, zu beurteilen.
Die Patientin muss ausführliche Flüssigkeit nehmen.
Manchmal.
Für die Oberfläche oder für die Galenblase muss die Patientin nüchtern sein.
Aber wegen einer Blutung oder wegen einer Trauma ist keine Vorbereitung nötig.
Sie haben gesagt, dass eine Kolonkarzinom als Defensivdiagnos kommt.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine Kolonkarzinom und welche sprechen gegen Kolonkarzinom?
Die Patientin hat 2 oder 3 Kilo abgenommen.
Das kann sprechen für eine Kolonkarzinom.
Sie hat zuständig die Diagnose.
Manchmal kommt Kolonkarzinom mit Diagnose.
Aber die Patientin hat seit 5 Jahren das Sprit gegen Kolonkarzinom.
Chronische Probleme.
Aber ich möchte Kolonkarzinom als Diffensivdiagnose haben.
Was denken Sie an B-Symptomatik bei diesen Patienten?
Die Patientin hat keine B-Symptomatik.
Beispielsweise keine Fieber, keine Schüttelfrost, keine Nachschweiß.
Diese Symptome schiebt sie auch gegen Kolonkarzinom.
Hat die Patientin ein Risiko für eine Kolonkarzinom?
Das Risiko für eine Kolonkarzinom ist, dass es keine Kolonkarzinom gibt.
Doch, der Vater oder?
Der Vater leidet an Kolonkarzinom.
Entschuldigung, ich habe falsch geschrieben.
Die Familienanamnese schiebt sie für eine Kolonkarzinom.
Das ist ein Risiko für Kolonkarzinom für die Patientin.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Könnten Sie bitte Koloskopie erklären?
Koloskopie ist ein bildgewendetes Verfahren.
Besonders die Dichtdarmspiegelung.
Mit Hilfe eines flexiblen Schlauchs, einer Kamera und Licht,
führen wir die Instrumente durch After-Ein bis 12-Finger-Darm.
Wir beurteilen die Kolonkarzinom- und 12-Finger-Darm-Krankheiten.
Ob es eine Koloskopie gibt oder ein Instrumente, können wir beurteilen.
Können wir mit Hilfe der Koloskopie Blutung und Gewebeprobe einnehmen?
Die Patientin sollte sich natürlich vorbereiten.
Vor zwei Tagen muss sie nur mit flüssiger Ernährung ernähren.
Vor einem Tag muss sie die Entzündung einnehmen und ihre Kolone entleeren.
Und mindestens acht Stunden muss die Patientin nüchtern sein.
Ohne Wasser, ohne oder zwölf Stunden kann nicht Wasser oder Flüssigkeit nehmen.
Welche Komplikationen können wir sehen?
Während einer Koloskopie können wir Kolonperforation oder Darmperforation sehen.
Und manchmal kann es natürlich Infektionen sein.
Nach der Koloskopie oder nach Blutung.
Kennen Sie BMI?
BMI ist Body Mass Index.
Das ist ein englischer Fachbegriff.
Das beurteilen wir als Adipositas.
BMI bedeutet Gewicht geteilt durch Großquadrat.
Zwischen 20 und 25 ist das Normalbereich.
Zwischen 25 und 30 bedeutet Übergewicht.
Über 30 bedeutet Obesity Adipositas.
Über 40 bedeutet Tötliche Adipositas.
Und weniger als 20 bedeutet Untergewicht.
Ok, gut.
Körpergewicht in Kilogramm geteilt durch Körpergroß in Meterquadrat.
Gut, Sie haben es gut gemacht.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Vielen Dank, Peroverus.
Herr Oberarzt, wir haben heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen gerne den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Es handelt sich um Frau Maria Nowak.
Sie ist 29 Jahre alt und 1 Meter 76 groß und 170 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 5 Jahren bestehender,
krampfartiger, durkender, dumpf, abdominal Schmerzen vor.
Die Beschwerden treten nach Aufnahme von Milchprodukten auf.
Sie ist deswegen diese Beschwerden.
Sie war letztes Jahr bei ihrem Hausarzt.
Die Einnahme von Metaspasmiden hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Beschwerden gehen mit Astenomethorismus flatulieren.
Außerdem sind sie in Klackte über Wasserigdiorä seit 3 Jahren.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist auffällig bis auf Inapadenz und Insomnie.
Es sind keine Bekannten für Erkrankungen bekannt.
Die Patientin wurde mit 5 Jahren aufgrund einer Diarrhea mit Stationäre behandelt.
Bei Patienten wurde eine Tonsiglaecoma mit 8 Jahren durchgeführt.
Sie ist allergisch gegen Polen und äußert sich mit Pyrrhythmias und Rhinitis.
Sie ist nicht Raucherin.
Sie trinkt eine Flasche Bier und eine Flasche Schnaps gelegentlich.
Drogenkonsum für die Ferneint.
In der Familienanamnese ist sie mit 50 Jahren an Koloncarcinom verstorben.
Sie hat Arteriellehypätonie.
Sie hat eine Brüder, die übergewischt hat.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Sie ist Stauberaterin und verheiratet.
Sie hat ein Kind und er ist gesund.
Sie lebt mit ihrer Familie.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Laktosintoleranz aus.
Da die Patienten dafür typische Symptome aufweisen,
bestätigen die Patienten, dass die Beschwerden nach Aufnahme von Milchprodukten auftreten.
Das ist sehr besonders für die Patienten.
Außerdem leidet sie unter Wasserige Dürre und Blahungen, Flatulenz, Meteorismus.
Das ist eine Expression für Laktosintoleranz.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Gastroenteritis, Morbus Crohn und Zölyaki aus Inbetrak.
Wenn ich die Patienten mit der Fitta-Parameter überwachen würde,
würde ich die Patienten körperlich unterziehen.
Ich würde die Patienten körperlich unterziehen.
Außerdem würde ich die Patienten körperlich unterziehen.
Wenn die Patienten die Abdominalgeräusche vermindern oder hören,
würde ich die Patienten körperlich unterziehen.
Das wäre ein Symbol für die Laborunterzüge, um die Diagnostik zu verhindern.
Dabei würde ich die Blutbildentzündung und die Elektrolyte,
die Lebewerte und die Nierenwerte bestimmen lassen.
Des Weiteren würde ich die Patienten die Zonographie des Abdomens durchführen,
um mögliche andere Veränderungen auszuschließen.
Gegenwarnungsweise würde ich den Patienten die Zitade des Abdomens durchführen,
um mögliche Abdominalpathologie auszuschließen.
Es ist sehr wichtig, den Patienten Laktos-Toleranz-Tests zu führen.
Wenn ich meine Verdachtstheorien bestätige, würde ich die Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Die Milchprodukte zu vermeiden, ist eine sehr wichtige Behandlung.
Außerdem würde ich die Patienten eine gastroenterologische Konzil anordnen,
um meine Therapie zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgelegenheit einverstanden sind,
würde ich mit den Genplanten und den Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Herr Kullinger, wie können Sie die Chronische Darmensündung auszuschließen?
Ich würde den Patienten eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Können Sie uns die Koloskopie ausdrücken?
Ja, die Koloskopie ist eine Bildgebende und Erzung.
Wir können die Koloskopie durchführen.
Ich werde die Änderungen ausprobieren.
Die Untersuchungen helfen uns, die Erkrankungen wie Morbus Crohn,
Userative Colitis, Schöljaki, Kolonkarsinoma und andere Kolonprobleme zu erkennen.
Das ist eine ungenäme Untersuchung.
Deswegen sollte der Patient eine Schlafmutter nehmen,
damit er während der Untersuchung schlafen kann.
Vor der Untersuchung sollten die Patienten mindestens 12 Stunden nicht essen und trinken.
Vor der Untersuchung können wir den Patienten eine Schlafmutter geben,
um die Taktarantlerung zu erzielen.
Bei der Untersuchung können wir eine Schlafmutter mit einer kleinen Kamera
durchführen, bis wir eine Schlafmutter haben.
Wir haben die Chance, eine Probe zu machen, um die Taktarantlerung zu erzielen.
Ich empfehle den Patienten, eine Gleichperson zu mitbringen,
damit er nicht eine wichtige Entscheidung treffen kann.
In manchen Fällen können andere Untersuchungsmethoden statt Essen
zu den Patienten gebracht werden.
Das kann durchgeführt werden.